Kylie Jenner poised to be the youngest
self-made billionaire ever cardi B and
offset welcomed their baby girl plus
Iggy Azalea is spilling the tea on
Azealia Banks and Demi Lovato hey guys
Danny here if you watched yesterday's
episode thank you I got a few really
sweet responses to my psychic reading I
just wanted to say quickly that I
appreciate the love and support it was
nice but let's get to the tea shall we
Forbes released their list of the
country's richest self-made female
entrepreneurs and that includes their
cover stars soon to be billionaire Kylie
Jenner Forbes estimates the cosmetic
queens worth to be nine hundred million
dollars and it all started with this $29
lip kit I know y'all try to get your
hands on it but all 15,000 kits sold out
in less than a minute and now in less
than three years Kylie is poised to be
the youngest self-made billionaire
that's where I said billionaire ever the
key while her personal connection to the
brand and let's not lie momager Kris
Jenner - I haven't learned everything
from my mom yet that I know that I need
to she teaches me something new every
day about everything she is my goals the
new mom tells Forbes that she is still
hoping instill that same drive in her
own daughter store me it says one day
she'll pass the company on to her if
she's into it that I say store me baby
you are set now what's awesome is that
et has been with Kylie since the
beginning before the lip fillers the
wigs and yes the booty in just six
months before she launched her near
billion-dollar makeup line Kylie told us
her inspiration everyone wants to see
like my makeup tips and what I do with
my hair and this and that so I just want
to do like tutorials and what I use
because I feel like people are really
interested in that so now also on the
list is reality star in Beauty Vogel
pudica tan ET style sat down with her
and that's up on our YouTube channel now
and Kylie's sister Kim Kardashian was
also one of the 60 lady bosses on Forbes
list ranking at number 54 while Kylie
was at number 27 but no hard feelings
there Kim
new Kylie's cover twice same Congrats
speaking of congratulations are in order
for cardi B because baby Bharti is
finally here
the rapper and husband offset welcomed
their first child together a baby girl
and broke the news on Instagram with
this very stunning and very subtle shot
of cardi and her baby bump in the
caption they revealed the name of her
baby and that's culture
yari cephus that's culture with the K by
the way so don't get it twisted but it
is interesting to note that offsets rap
group Lee goes has a 2017 album named
culture cardi secretly tied the knot
with rapper off set last September and
she kept her pregnancy under wraps until
April when she put her baby bump on full
display during her performance on SM now
and I don't know about you guys but I
felt like that baby was never gonna come
out but that didn't slow down cardi or
her unborn daughter for that matter baby
oh hey she wants a favor she does coming
up it's hard enough to get up the Met
Gala stairs now you got a baby yes
[Applause]
[Music]
switching gears to another female rapper
who is back in the game miss Iggy Azalea
the Aussie rapper dropped her latest
single cream but when she stopped by
here to chat with our Sophie she Lacey
he got candid about her friend Demi
Lovato's recent relapse how's she doing
your tweet to her was so sweet after
everything she was going through I know
I had known about it
sure I'm so close as a close friend so I
had really wanted for her to be the one
to tell people that and I worried a lot
just as her friend that you know
something was gonna leak or somebody
would somehow like take that and use it
negatively against her or to make her
seem like she's got a secret you know so
it's not my business to say to your
friend that you need to yeah but it's
your friend you know you worry and
you're like oh my god my friends she has
this thing that people could use against
her and I really want her to like write
and she did
I just was really proud of her that she
was honest because it's really hard to
be honest with yourself
so to be honest with the whole world
about something that you've struggled
with very publicly I think that it's
very admirable and I was very proud of
her to see her write that song and put
it out and to see everybody's reception
being so understanding of where she's at
I thought I was really cool by the way
we also asked Iggy for her reaction to
Azealia Banks praising her new video
they've had a complicated history to say
the least and here's what she had to say
about that you also got a shout out
actually from you've had a complicated
history but Azealia Banks did you see
that she tweeted about genuinely didn't
say that but she's always tweeting I
think about everything well I have well
yeah she is
somebody had tweeted that your video is
out and she said that she's not under
the news a good job and that you look
sexy in the video I'll take it to today
the editor she changes her mind so much
but today I will take a couple all right
I don't know if it was still stand there
great but I'll take there's always
something different with you - yeah we
have more on Iggy and azalea's beef on
et online.com but that's it for right
now tomorrow though we are going live on
the daily Denny at 12 p.m. Pacific 3
p.m. Eastern with a very special guest
but you have to come back then to find
out okay bye
you